parvenu à coups de l'unifolié baigneurs
étaient attendues sans tourner dans des
films en noir et blanc est tué
c'est du chocolat c'est délicieux bravo
d'habitués vraiment un grand passé on
est ravis d'or cet égard n'avait-il et
parpaings pas dans les ouvertures de
porte sur les murs ou d'affaires
[Musique]
bon ben voilà il faut aujourd'hui
qu'elle aura recours qu'à nos 20 ans
plus tard tu es triste software dans la
vie il ya des cactus il est impossible
de savoir dans la vie il y a des cactus
[Musique]
ouvrez la bouche ouvrez la bouche vous
d'habitude tata nano marie geof mybook
avons tous à l'eau
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de chambon pas mais nous
non ya pas non plus de boudin nous mange
pas bon vivre où tu voudras attendu
vouloir et au fameux ventre lorsque
l'amour à mort luna dit ressemblera ce
matin comme un jeu ou j'te gage un coude
babouche des bénéfices
si je vous en ferez et si tu reviens
mechta comme le poing levé villa comment
as tu trouvé la prestation
[Musique]
je ne leur ai pas mais non c'était très
bien et bravo pour la valise à offrir au
préau one trip en prime comme des
américains
[Musique]